[Music]
who's heard of this uh medical uh
professional term before it's called uh
blue balls never heard of that dude
never never heard of it never bro oh man
we'll talk about this stuff here
[Music]
[Laughter]
anymore it's just insulting
[Laughter]
you're like the unruly kid in class
[ __ ] you teacher that guy's so cool
teacher never yells at him all right
cool yeah he's like that's bart only
barker get away with it that's the end
of that one yeah yeah yeah uh what do
you guys want to talk about what about
blue balls man
what about blue ball what did you i've
never had blue balls before have you
guys had it no i never had it i thought
it was just like a joke because i've
heard things from the week
and then like like they're making out
their chick or whatever and then they
get hard and they end up like the chick
goes home and then they're like oh my
[ __ ] balls hurt and i'm like damn i
never experienced that they were
complaining how bad of her i thought it
was made up purely as a way of coercion
it could be that's it i'm like 90 on
that page except for i do feel like i've
had blue balls one time in high school
and it's because back in high school
and and for me personal story like that
i i didn't like have sex yet so like but
i was doing a bunch of stuff with like
my lady you know what i mean so try it
like what describe it
don't look at me like that itemize it
the scratching nick
durations please
look down and inspect and be like oh
[ __ ] they're blue
yeah just slap it against the wall yeah
i mean what is the root of that no no
but but i do i do remember i do remember
like being you know like very very
active and then not busting a nut and
then like later on just done whoa like
this this feels very uncomfortable what
were your symptoms it just like feels
uncomfortable
that's it your balls just hurt it's like
you need to get something out but could
you walk could you is it like
you know it's like it's like it's like
when you have to like take a [ __ ] or
something like that right there's just
an internal discomfort that doesn't
necessarily like impair yourself so the
pressure is built you had a pressure
build yeah you had a pressure build did
you release that pressure eventually
absolutely by myself thank you only guy
who can rely on himself as a real man
should i did it improve your dancing is
what we want to know i was in dance in
high school it was spiteful point is the
point is though
that a sex expert does explain why bl
blue balls isn't an actual thing it's
mental right
uh
it's actually a lot more of what ryan's
hinting at
coercion
that's what that's what this sex expert
is saying i bet i bet that's true i mean
what what what makes you a sex expert
like you [ __ ] a lot who me personally no
i mean or if you if you watch people
have sex a lot does that make you yeah
i mean like i studied the tape like i
have the red line all the time
i think that'll make us all sex back to
us
sexpert a sexpert but wait was this was
this lots of research expert a a male or
female what do you think this uh his
name is nadia his name is nadia then how
the [ __ ] was she know
i mean i've never experienced it but i
was like that's [ __ ] woman's
explaining she has she has to uh come up
with an actually she's a [ __ ] doctor
or something
is she measuring blue balls wouldn't
that be really great if like after
watching so much porn pornhub just sends
you a plaque the way youtube sends you
like a that'll be like you are now a sex
expert you got the platinum button yeah
you get a platinum port we've been we've
been monitoring you through your webcam
and you visited the site a hundred
thousand you know what you're doing at
this point you don't know what you're
doing
i should not be raising good cookies
confetti blows up on your screen and
says congratulations [ __ ] incognito
mode ruined my chances
of at least a million views on incognito
mode
all right so this sex expert nadia
pakodi uh has been dropping these truth
bombs about blue balls saying that men
will sometimes claim they are suffering
from the affliction
when they are denied sexual pleasure
that amounts to a climax that's the most
elegant way of putting that well you
said coercion that's a pretty good word
i always thought guys just said it to
get girls to finish the job they're like
oh come on babe don't give me blue balls
pretty poetic i never said that oh you
know what's interesting too the only
time i ever heard about blue balls was
in high school yeah it's like i never
hear it past high school that's because
you getting it you know
you know me man
you have a sex bro
but i feel like i think that is a myth
that is that is probably a myth
i'd be having sex dude there's a guy who
listens
every time i heard of people talking
about like blue balls though
there'll be like a group of guys that
would agree like oh yeah man it hurts up
there oh yeah me too
yeah yeah they do that [ __ ]
and i'm just like y'all got weak dicks
man
that's so weak
i never had a blue ball what is that
yeah i never had blue balls
i don't know we dig this guy
after he like shared his story
no way story i told never even happened
never had blue balls uh speaking of the
poetic terms uh this this lady nadia is
explaining that blue balls isn't real
and is instead used as a quote-unquote
guilt tactic
damn you hit it she might be women
splaining a little bit
yeah what's her experience how does she
know how does she go
hey eric you know uh so your son's 18
and you're pretty close in age yeah did
you and you're ready get ready
y'all are both 18. i did actually you
did yeah you know our parents are both
18.
no you're not our parents you look so
young yeah seriously
how did this 18 year old have an 18 year
old
how's that massive dramatically possible
you just like incubated him longer
it's actually a twin that he held on to
a twin that he held on to came out he's
like aunt came out first you're my son
not my brother 18 years later yeah he
came out good for you yeah cause like
our parents that they just skipped that
talk you know so like i think we're the
new generation and we're asian americans
we want to give that talk but hasn't
come yet and i don't know if we're that
open for you you guys are really close
right and you guys are buying [ __ ]
nfts and [ __ ] together yeah taika looks
like he's ready
he already knows
well according to him right now he's gay
that's what he said yeah because he
looks at girls
not only that he's ancestral he's in
sexuality because i asked him who he
wanted to marry and he goes ew not a
girl i want to marry my cousin which is
you got to try it all out you got to try
your boy cousins these are the signs two
of them two of them he wants to marry
two of them so what's kind of what's
kind of interesting about that is like
we we live in this world of cultural
norms and all these things are learned
and tyka's in this like innocent phase
where he hasn't learned what culture
dictates how we're supposed to be so he
has no idea
yeah so all of these like so that's his
natural self that's that's like you know
just a cousin loving gay guy
we need more of those in the world
obviously yeah i'm just putting two and
two together you have to change this
paperwork now or
that's not monogamous that's true yeah
what a chauvinist
are the cousins brothers
they're twins they're twin boys
so no sex talk
no i've had the sex talk with him at
what age and what age did you tell him
he's like all right so you know this nft
right well he was 16.
he's like you know the lana rhodes nft
rug pool right
okay so the analogy is do you have this
rug pulled here and sometimes you got to
protect yourself
from these rug pools no i had to talk
with him when he was 16. pretty good and
uh it it was you know awkward he'd be
like dad what are you what are you
telling me i was like i need to at least
like have this conversation what's the
opening sentence yeah everyone probably
what's the problem man like what made
you go i got to talk about this look at
him like he's your son yeah you guys you
guys do you guys touch on blue balls at
all because i i mean
is that in there at all i guess i need
to reference this uh this sex expert
because i think my opening statement
would be like
like let's say he's like 14 or opening
statement
have you ever been horny
you know that is a tough opening bro
you don't want yourself that's like dad
yeah you don't want your dad asking for
14 yeah
if they have my genetics they're [ __ ]
beating off at like 10.
i think the opening statement has got to
be like relative to him it's like
so
i was on your computer
and i saw some stuff
let's talk about it that's good what is
this grinder
why are you using your pc for it
stop being such a weird kid use your
phone don't use the desktop version when
you crack are you gonna kill people what
are you hacking it
yeah how did you how did you break it to
him um so he was he met a girl online
they were playing fortnite or something
like that and he started having like an
online relationship
um and then i was like hey you know like
i know it's virtual and she's overseas
but we should at least have this
conversation don't send your dick pic
boy
yeah you don't wanna put that [ __ ] out
there because if you wanna you know who
knows what a job job right who knows
what's his name is
[Laughter]
so i just basically said hey you know
like we should we should have this
conversation let's sit down and it
started off awkward and i was just
telling him hey you know if you want to
go sleep with a girl it's totally cool
i'm okay with it just use protection
here's some condoms things like that
that's tight um what is it was he
receptive get out of here lame dad he
was like the whole time he's like he's
like okay dad is the most awkward
conversation ever but he was there you
know he was present for it yeah he's
probably this is so weird can we just
leave them there
just leave them there what are the first
steps what should i do
but i think it's like it's important to
have that communication because like
you're right like my parents never said
anything like that never explained
anything like that so like when when
when i got to the age of you know being
sexually active i had no idea what's
going on my mom just said i hope you're
not buying hookers
she goes her son they're my friends from
high school
they're not hookers yeah were you buying
hookers [ __ ] hookers
you might watch a lot of cops
that's so funny
because like most of us we only get our
sexual education from high school yeah
from like the gym or the pheasant even
though right yeah we were lucky with the
internet we got movies
we got lucky that's true i think i was
hooking up and my mom heard her moan
and then it just happened one too many
times because i'm a sex expert and then
so she's like i hope you're not buying
hookers and i'm like no we're like
together because i think she would
understand that you should have like
she's paying for me
i think first-gen internet generation
like that's pretty [ __ ] up to learn
about sex that way dude all i remember i
don't know how old you guys are but when
when i was younger we had the only way
we could download porn is through bbses
so you had to do dial up you know when
you like use the mode makes all the
weird screeching noises and the moment
somebody picks up the phone your
connection's over yeah so you'd go onto
like these bbs's dial into somebody's
house and download these jpegs of porn
and then and then your parents would
pick up the phone and make a call and
you'd only have half the picture so
you're beating off to like just this
headshot here
you're just imagining what's happening
yeah that's why we had a floppy disk
where we would download and drag it into
the floppy but even loading those up it
still opens up
[Laughter]
pornography so i think it's even more
important to explain like yeah that's
true because the desensitization of it
is like
what gets them off when they're like
finally in their 20s it can really
damage their heads the first porn i ever
saw was like i was like super young i
think i was like 12 and i had aol
and i went to this chat room where
people were just doing like sending porn
to each other the first [ __ ] picture
i saw was a girl and she had like a
strap-on
like connected to her face and she was
anal a different chick and i went whoa i
was like
this is what my parents [ __ ] do
this is what's sexist
that's crazy is this [ __ ] i was like mom
you do this
mom do you do this i was like i don't
know if you need this much equipment
with other women logistical nightmares
it took a lot to finally see the correct
porn dude i got a chin strap
you went straight from the deep end dude
[Music]
[Music]
you